and wild yes it was a great energy we
should you know Marvel showcased footage
for all their upcoming films we got to
cap it off and that was that will felt
that felt great people really responded
it seemed like and just great to be back
here in Hawley well in Hall H at Comic
Con we're really the guardians franchise
was born you know those people have been
that in that in their seats for nine
hours yeah or most of the time anyway
and and what's nice at the end of the
day you got to show that footage and and
when you're on the set every day you
know you hope you're doing good but it's
nice to see that reaction they really
they're they were perfect for it when
Chris and James I guess were the guys
who kind of like said yeah Kurt Russell
would be the right guy for for that that
verifies that choice you know and that's
a good feeling because it's it's a big
part of making the movie work i I'm
really impressed with what I saw tonight
I think this movie is going to be
absolutely great the fans at comic-con
you look at a group of people who are
just having fun you know they are
passionate about the various worlds in
one of them being the you know cosmic
Marvel Cinematic Universe and we're a
big part of that and so people are
really passionate they love these
characters they want to they just love
these movies it's a big part of their
life because they get to have fun I saw
so many kids today dressed up like Groot
or rocket or star-lord and it's just I
don't know it's really moving I would
god I legitimately got moved to tears on
stage if they're seeing that footage I'm
just so proud of the movie when you
remember that the word fan is short for
fanatic this place reminds you of it
they're fanatic people about what they
watch and they love this franchise I
mean III came to it late and had to you
know get cat to play catch-up and it's
just a blast to see people who love they
love his character the baby Groot in
this thing is just going to be
spectacular but they love all the
characters and it's all about James
Gunn's ability
to create a story that you get
interested in and he does it very
quickly James had the idea he wanted to
have the Ravagers be a part of the of
our of our panel so what happens is the
Ravagers yeah James Gunn's introduced he
comes out says hi to the audience
you know everybody's applauding and he's
having a great time and when he starts
talking he starts getting interrupted by
all these this bunch of mutts coming in
from all angles from from the audience
perfects perspective but walking through
the crowds walking through the audience
is causing epic and and just abusing
James Gunn the whole way Hall H is just
so big and every fan in there screaming
and hollering so it's you know really in
between each introduction there's like a
good four minutes of screaming you just
got to let it go you can't fight it
right here's my sister
I'm her sister
adopted sister there is a lot of
excitement and we were able to show like
a little sneak peek of what we've been
up to this year which has been a lot of
fun it's the first time for us to watch
it so we feel right now just like the
fans like super excited super highs and
we can't believe we have to wait till
May you can't believe oh good the fridge
was so good it's really inspiring and
it's also like how could we not bring a
film like this that is it's it's it goes
it's like in the epicentre what we did
what we define is fandom so for us to
not come to a convention that was
created for the sole purpose of
celebrating what you're so devoted to is
ludicrous right and over here what we
get from as actors that are in these
movies
I mean it's infectious all this great
energy all this support all this love
makes you feel excited to do what we do
and makes us want to do it even better
you know next time nebula and the
Ravagers are kind of like you know
nebula doesn't mind a Ravager boy she's
alright with those she's always been
that crazy little sister I have to say
you know it's so crazy it's a it's
really it's an odd honoured feeling that
we were safe for last haha we had a
great big productions and the applause
the excitement from the crowd is just
overwhelming but you know what really is
cool about that is you really see how
people just embraced the first film and
they really embrace these characters and
they just love them so much and they're
so excited so it has such a great
feeling that's a it's a little
overwhelming you know it's a little
overwhelming but it's it's it's
incredible
we're also excited to see it that
literally when the lights went out we
are as a whole cast jump down on the
floor so we can look up and watch this
but that's how you know we're excited as
well because we're out you know we're
all though we're all on the film there's
some a lot of the parts that we didn't
see they were filming on with other
characters and we haven't seen it so
we're you know we're just fans just as
much as anybody else I was coming here
as a fan before I was coming here to
work so this it's more odd for me to be
here on this side I'm used to being on
the other side and a on watching the
panels and watching all you know the
superheroes that I love on film so it's
a little still a little bit hot for me
to be on this side yeah and on the
inside looking out when I was always on
the outside looking in it's a little bit
weird but I it's kind of a cool thing
because I really understand that I
really understand the emotion that's
involved in how much you embrace these
characters and love these characters and
can possibly be disappointed so we want
to deliver you know and I as a fan of
fanboy okay I want to deliver I take
pride in that so hopefully uh I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty confident that people
are gonna love this film actually the
first time that I saw the the footage
you know so I saw my character of course
for the first time that completely you
know the CGI really cool and also the
the other everything else was so cool
and the excitement of you know being in
the room and everyone yelling and it was
recessional it was my first comic-con
you know so you know it was one of my
dreams to be in a Marvel movie to play
an alien to do weird things and that's
what I that's what I did so though it's
great I mean you know it just was just a
gift to all to play this character and
written so well bye bye James I think
James is a genius it was pretty amazing
it was it was a little bit overwhelming
and and actually really beautiful it was
such a sea of love out there and people
just loved the film so much and to be a
part of it is a real privilege as an
actor
so I just felt really lucky to be up
there and I was just as excited as
everyone I think to see the footage
because I haven't seen anything yet so
yeah it was great it's sort of like
really really touching and it's like why
and I just think it's such a rare thing
in the world and like on on a meta level
to have some something that people care
so much about and I think the beautiful
thing about Marvel films as a general
note is they're just so entertaining
they're just pure wonderful
entertainment and there's something for
everyone I mean tonally they're all so
different but to have something in the
world that sort of brings that to people
and to have people so passionate about
it I think is a really really important
and special thing so you know when we
were standing - waiting waiting to go
onto stage and someone was saying people
have been camped out for 24 hours I just
thought it was incredible you know and
so you want to make it wonderful for
them we went down into Hall H and we
showed some stuff from guardians of
galaxy - we showed a clip from the movie
we showed a little special San Diego
comic-con teaser we showed a little bit
of behind the scenes because we created
a ride for guardians of the galaxy for
Disneyland theme parks Disneyland here
in California and and we had a bunch of
jerky Ravagers on stage came up and
heckled us all the way throughout so it
was a quite an experience in Hall H the
fans here so many of them who came to
Hall H like waited out in line for 36
hours to get in there for a short
glimpse of guardians I really
appreciated it it's an amazing type of
love to feel from the audience and I
hope they know how much I care about
them and that's my greatest interest is
creating something for them that is
different from anything else that's out
there and that's what guardians the
galaxy vol wasn't lost
and I think volume 2 is even more so
you